[Music]
keenan starts off this hour in ames iowa
hi kanan how are you i'm doing great
dave how about you better than i deserve
how can i help
hey i've heard you talk multiple times
about being up front about what's in
your will while you're still alive so
it's not a surprise later right most
commonly when you talk about that you're
talking about or you use an example
talking about an older person with their
adult kids and all that
my wife and i are in our early 30s we
have young children under six
we just got our will set up about a year
ago and as part of that we realized we
have one side of the family with whom
we're very comfortable leaving
them in charge of things for our kids if
we were to both die and one side of our
family in which we're not very
comfortable
without any of that and um
my
i want to talk about it with the side of
the family that is being cut out per se
my wife does not and we talked with the
rest of
it's my family that we would be leaving
them with we talked with the rest of my
family and
all of them said the same thing
don't do it
i'm looking for your thoughts is there
anything else we should be considering
with this they basically thought it
would be
starting a fight that doesn't need to be
started
there's gonna be a fight yeah you might
as well do it while you're alive
yeah
because because her family's a bunch of
yehus man
they're the ones that are going to take
your family into court and try to i'm
going to get the kids
it'll be a hillbilly hoedown man
yeah
i'm sorry dude but i mean uh do you you
want your relatives all drug into court
by her crazy family
exactly no this is what's going to
happen yeah you know everybody else here
just doesn't want to do conflict that's
all it is
but there's a conflict coming and it's
going to be a bigger one after you're
dead
right and i will and we wouldn't be
there to be a part of it and help
exactly hold the middle ground
personally no it's hey it's got to
remind everybody here
this my money hello it's my kids
the rest of you people don't get to have
an opinion or if you have one it doesn't
matter you don't get a vote in this yeah
and i'm being sarcastic and bombastic
but you wouldn't ever talk to your
family or family actually that way but
you know i'm not going to be intimidated
by their reaction without doing about
not doing the right thing i'm just going
to say hey we talked about it this is
going to be handling the kiddos
what about um
since it's my wife's family i would
assume i should probably not be the
person to
break the news
at least not the principal person to
break the news and my wife doesn't want
to do it do we just keep talking about
it between ourselves and hope we come
around to that
well i mean your wife has to get on has
to agree to do this before you do it
you're not gonna you know you're not
gonna violate that this is that's a
that's an argument between you and your
wife
right and the two of you have got to
settle on that she doesn't want to do it
because she don't deal with the conflict
yeah and
there's a whole lot of toxicity on that
side already with other life decisions
we're making with getting out of debt
and all that kind of stuff so
[Music]
uh it's fun yeah i mean there's nothing
there's not unless someone's ill there's
not an emergency
right but it's just bad practice
to allow the intimidation of the
toxicity to set the tone
yeah and that's what's going on and so
you know
um
so you know it may take a little while
and it might be if the
you know like if she just opens her
mouth and her mother opens her mouth at
the same time that automatically there's
a fight if that's the case maybe you're
the one that leads the conversation if
there's a if there's just a bad script
between her
and her mom and dad for instance okay
siblings are even less of a concern but
it's her mom and dad and so if there's
just a bad script there it might be that
you're seen as the level-headed one from
the outside you might be the evil one
from the outside i don't know the evil
one oh are you okay i'm the controlling
husband that wants to make his wife sell
everything so we can get out of that and
it's like no this is
100 on board together with this this is
well i mean you might just play that on
out going i'm also the controlling
husband that's already figured out our
will and the kids are going to the other
side
might as well just be if you're going to
be controlling you might as well do it
from the grave right yeah
oh this is i'm sorry this is such a hard
thing i'm poking around it but we all
have this stuff or most people do in
their family most people have crazy
right up in their face
and so um
it's hard but i
really think that her parents if they're
that toxic
will give your parents or your brother
and sister whoever it is a hard time and
it might cost them a lot of legal fees
yeah or just a whole lot of grudge that
my our kids would be getting a whole lot
of
under the table under their breath talk
type of thing they may get that anyway
they may get that anyway you may not be
able to stop that
but um but but you know
the good news is is that hopefully it
never happens that you guys you know you
live until your kids are not minors and
those kinds of things right but um
you know i i think that's just a
decision you and your wife have to make
together it's it's ill-advised to not
bring
everyone into the loop because
the other person that feels
uh shorted
in the thing especially people that are
this toxic
have a tendency to go legal on you and
it just it they could eat up everything
and because they feel righteous in their
fight for your kids
you know
yeah they write this script out where
everyone else is evil and they're the
righteous ones
and that's how that's how that's where
these people go to extremes and so i
don't know it's up to you the more crazy
it is though the more i think you ought
to do it so i think you and your wife
just keep talking about it though and if
your wife doesn't want to handle it and
you want to just go ahead and be the bad
guy you can just be the kind bad guy and
just go guys i don't really want to have
this conversation but i feel like i need
to so
i'm going to go ahead and tell you
what's going on and just so you know and
it's a quick thing it's really not
asking we're not taking a vote here i'm
just kind of telling you what's going on
we've laid out our wills and everything
and should something happen to us our
wheels are iron
clad our lawyer says they cannot be
broken and here's what our wishes are
and here's what's going to happen with
the kids and hey we love you guys and we
hope everything gets a little better
with you all and that you can quit
talking trash at us all the time but if
you can't it's going to be up to you i
mean but i just want to let you know the
whole thing and you could just have that
conversation but you don't want to do
that without your wife being on board
but if you're already in the bad guy
seat i guess you can just take the seat
and run with it you know it's just
man
some of these people
some people's children there you go you
know it's unbelievable
thanks for the call i appreciate you
joining us pick up the book boundaries
and give it a good read
henry clouds famous
life lessons book for all of you that
think you're crazy because your family
is boundaries is a great book
it's a great book
oh my gosh it's everywhere y'all i mean
i if you don't think there's crazy in
your family it's probably you
most families got a little in it right
there you go this is the dave ramsey
show